you know they really got to get into
when he started drinking smoking and
gambling
I want that there's a couple things are
not explaining first of all very basic
thing from last episode I forgot to
bring up I want to know why the [ __ ]
against the Lakers he went up and under
on that one play that everybody the
highlight where he's going up with his
right hand and then comes down with his
left and [ __ ] what - because he could
have just went up magic lifts amazing
also 20 bucks in the 90s about 40 bucks
and purchasing power today yeah that's
kind of what I figured wait till I'm old
so I could do that to my kids that's how
that [ __ ] happened you know parallel now
you get a Snickers for a nickel
I was I've been think about this the
whole time this Yochanan drinking during
the podcast only but him smoking
drinking whatever and there's a scene in
98 where I guess they're I don't know
what's going him and Scotty after a win
they got to like 60 wins or whatever
yeah they're drinking beer with Phil
yeah just drinking a beer right after
the game and then Michael's like back
when I was to play back when I was a
rookie the easier smoke cigarettes at
halftime drink coach whatever and he's
drinking his beer but then the second he
walks outside it's like 250 media people
all waiting for him Mike's right in his
face I mean it's a [ __ ] sea of people
and the first question so is this your
last game here and it's like man [ __ ] I
know you imagine it boy you would need
to drink just to deal with that I wonder
if yes you're a hundred percent right I
wonder if he did that on purpose because
he enjoyed the attention he enjoyed the
power making the organization wonder if
it says last year make the organization
do whatever he wants
you know bend the knee
because they're like we got to be nice
to Michael I mean maybe he looked at yo
real talk maybe he didn't trust Krauss
maybe he looked at the way Krauss
treated Pippen he looked at the way
Krauss treated other players on the team
he's like yo I locked myself down for
another six years seven years eight
years ten years then they could do
whatever the [ __ ] they want with me they
could dangle me as a carrot for trades
they could completely ignore all my
demands cuz they got me locked in the
only way I can maintain leverage here is
if I say I if I sign these will one-year
deals or two-year deals whatever he did
those last two years were two-year deals
maybe one year when your one-year deals
so I assigned a short deals kind of like
what LeBron was doing right that's how I
maintain leverage with this organization
because they're not gonna [ __ ] fire
this fat [ __ ] Jerry Krause so what I'll
do is make crowds do whatever I say it's
kind of a smart move but then you got to
deal with the cost of that no but to
your point about wanting people to wait
and whatever I think you said this on
another episode you think he knew he was
gonna retire there's a scene in this -
owed six or five but the hotel the
camera crew comes in to his hotel room
and he's laid out on the couch smoking a
cigar and he's like this is not a life
you envy this is the only have like
privacy that I get is in his hotel room
before you move - more wine and more
loved wine and look but he's crying but
he did he does say I will not miss this
and I am done with this and I will not
miss it and I think he might have been
saying I know I'm a retired I'm done
yeah I'm done but that's what I'm
thinking you might whispers of you hope
you hold it over everybody's head cuz
you kind of like the drama these guys
all like drama LeBron loves drama
Michael loves drama I love the attention
they love that holding it over people's
head like you said they love something
about it that is you're gonna wonder all
year it's a Power Move you know how he
said when he went he would go up and
he'd uh he'd gamble with will Perdue and
John Paxson yeah in their card game yeah
and he goes in there like why you coming
here like you guys are playing card
games in the back of it worth like you
know tens of thousands of dollars we're
playing one dollar a hand poker yeah
because I love your money in my pocket
that's a power thing yeah that is an
alpha thing what is Jordan's biggest
deal he needs to be the Alpha yeah he's
going at the Alpha first practice for
the Bulls I'm trying to find
the best players I'm going at him right
he's in the Bulls organization and they
don't let him feel like the Alpha right
they'll let him have his coach yeah they
don't let him fire the GM yeah that's
got it eat at him so what do I have to
do I'm gonna do a Power Move I'm
stepping away from the game [ __ ] you
okay I'll come back but I'm gonna come
back only if you pay me this amount of
money and I get to do whatever I want
and we get to maintain this boom third
year on the second three-peat I'm not
coming back and Phil's not coming back
the Jerry Reinsdorf goes to [ __ ]
Wyoming Montana whatever it is please
come back for one more year Phil that
this is him trying to prove that he's
the Alpha the organization yeah
[Applause]